19 public health emergency today's
hearing is being held remotely
all members and witnesses will be
participating
via video conferencing as part of our
hearing
microphones will be set on mute for the
purpose of eliminating inadvertent
background noise
members and witnesses you will need to
unmute your microphones each time you
wish to speak
additionally members will need to be
visible on screen in order to be
recognized
due to the anticipated length of this
hearing the committee will take a
fifteen minute recess
around three o'clock to provide
witnesses and members a restroom break
finally documents for the record can be
sent to ed
asmarsky and joe orlando at the email
addresses we have provided to your staff
all documents will be entered into the
record at the conclusion
of the hearing the chair will now
recognize himself
for five minutes our nation
is drowning in disinformation driven by
social media
platforms that were once used to share
photos of kids with grandparents
are all too often havens of hate
harassment
and division the way i see it there are
two faces to each of your platforms
facebook has family and friends
neighborhood but it is right next to the
one where there is a white nationalist
rally every day
youtube is a place where people share
quirky videos
but down the street anti-vaxxers covet
deniers
chewing on supporters and flat earthers
are sharing videos
twitter allows you to bring friends and
celebrities into your home
but also holocaust deniers terrorists
and worse
now it would be one thing if every user
chose where to go organically
but almost everything is scripted on
social media platforms
facebook recognizes anti-social
tendencies in one user
and invites them to visit the white
nationalists
youtube sees another user as interested
in kobit 19
and auto starts an anti-vaxx video
on twitter a user following the trending
conversation
never knowing it is driven by bots and
coordinated disinformation networks
run by foreign agents your platforms
have changed how people across the
planet communicate
connect learn and stay informed the
power of this technology is awesome
and terrifying and each of you has
failed to protect your users
and the world from the worst consequence
of your creations
this is the first time the three of you
have appeared before congress
since the deadly attack on the capital
on january 6th
that event was not just an attack on our
democracy in our electoral process
but an attack on every member of this
committee and in the congress
many of us were on the house floor and
in the capital when that attack occurred
and we were forced to stop our work of
certifying the election
and retreat to safety some of us wearing
gas masks and fearing for our lives
we fled as a mob desecrated the capital
the house floor
and our democratic process people died
that day and hundreds were seriously
injured
that attack and the movement that
motivated started and was nourished on
your platforms
your platform suggested groups for
people to join
videos they should view and post they
should like
driving this movement forward with
terrifying speed and efficiency
fbi documents show that many of these
individuals
use your platforms to plan recruit and
execute this attack according to
independent research
users on facebook were exposed 1.1
billion times
to misinformation related to the
election last year alone
despite changes to your policies and
claims that you've removed election
misinformation
our nation is in the middle of a
terrible pandemic
nearly 550 000 americans have lost their
lives to this deadly disease
to see just as well and twitter was no
different
if you go to any of these super spreader
accounts that remain up despite the
policies
meant to curb this anti-vaxx content
you'll see this content
now understand this you can take this
content down
you can reduce the vision you can fix
this
but you choose not to we saw your
platforms remove
isis terrorist content we saw you tamp
down uncovered misinformation at the
beginning of the pandemic
and we have seen this disinformation
drop when you have promoted reliable
news sources and remove
serial disinformation super spreaders
from your platform
you have the means but time after time
you are picking engagement
and profit over the health and safety of
your users
our nation and our democracy
these are serious issues and to be
honest it seems like you all just shrug
off billion dollar fines
your companies need to be held
accountable we need rules
regulations technical experts in
government and audit authority of your
technologies
ours is the committee of jurisdiction
and we will
legislate to stop this the stakes are
simply too high
the chair will now recognize mr latta
ranking member of the subcommittee on
communications and technology
for five minutes for his opening
statement well i thank the chairman for
recognizing me
and i want to thank our witnesses for
being with us today
for a conversation that's long overdue
in the energy and commerce committee
i'm deeply concerned by your decisions
to operate your companies in a vague and
biased manner
for little to no accountability while
using section 230
as a shield for your actions and their
real world consequences
your companies have the power to silence
president united states shut off
legitimate journalism
in australia shut down legitimate
scientific debate on a variety of issues
dictate which articles or websites are
seen by americans when they search the
internet
when these actions are taken users have
little to no recourse to appeal the
decision
if they are aware of your actions in
most cases we simply don't know
what does this mean for everyday
americans we are all aware
of big tech's ever increasing censorship
of conservative voices
and their commitment to serve the
radical progressive agenda by
influencing a generation of children
and removing shutting down or cancelling
any news books and even now toys that
aren't considered woke
this is fundamentally un-american at a
recent hearing on disinformation and
extremism online professor turley one of
the nation's foremost experts
on constitutional law testified about
the little brother problem
a problem which private entities do for
the government which it cannot legally
do for itself
as of january of this year google has a
greater than 92
market share in search facebook has over
2.7
billion billion monthly users and
twitter has
187 million daily users your companies
have enormous control over whose ideas
are seen read or heard around the world
this gives you great power and if
misused as we have seen in recent years
your actions have a ripple effect
throughout the world
that result in american voices being
removed from the marketplace of ideas
while the little brother problem of
censorship is frightening enough
other serious harms are occurring on
these platforms
that affect ordinary americans young
american children and teenagers are
addicted
actually addicted to their devices and
social media
this problem has been exacerbated by the
pandemic and will only get worse if
children continue to be separated
from their peers and cannot learn from
their teachers in a classroom
your platforms are purposely designed to
keep our children hooked
to their screens the use of social media
has been linked to increased rates of
depression
mental illness cyber bullying and
suicide among
america's youth illegal drugs continue
to be sold online despite your previous
commitments to solve these issues
mr chairman i i do ask unanimous consent
to submit a letter
to the national association of boards of
pharmacy or the record
thank you very much serious problems
continue to persist and i wonder how
much you are truly dedicating
to combating these actions what actions
are you taking to educate
americans about the dangers of using
your site especially the dangers for
kids as ranking member of the
subcommittee on communications and
technology
we have oversight of any change made to
section 230 of the communications
decency act
section 230 provides you with the
with liability protection for content
moderation decisions
made in good faith based on recent
actions however it is clear
that your definition of good faith
moderation includes censoring viewpoints
you disagree with and establishing full
independent appeals
process that doesn't make its content
moderation decision
based on american principles of free
expression
i find that highly concerning
i look forward to today's hearing as an
important step in reconsidering the
extent to which big tech deserves to
retain
the significant liability protection and
with that mr chairman i yield back the
balance of my time
thank you gentlemen yields back the
chair now recognizes chair shikowski
chair of the subcommittee on consumer
protection and commerce
for five minutes for her opening
statement
thank you it's a pleasure to co-chair
this meeting with you
i want to welcome our witnesses and
thank them for coming
it is not an exaggeration to say that
your companies
have fundamentally and permanently
transformed
our very culture and our understanding
of the world
much of this is for good
but it is also true that our
country our democracy even our
understanding of what
is truth has been harmed by
the pro the proliferation and dissent
dissemination
of misinformation and extremism
all of which has deeply divided us
what our witnesses today need to take
away from this hearing
is that self-regulation has come to the
end of its road
and that this democracy this this
democratic
democr the people that you see before
you um
uh elected to by the people
um is uh preparing to move forth
with with legislation and regulation
the regulation that we seek should not
attempt to limit
constitutionally protected freedom of
speech
but it must hold platforms accountable
when they are used in to incite violence
and hatred
or as in the case of the covet pandemic
spread misinformation that costs
thousands of lives
all three of the of the uh companies
that are here today
run platforms that are hotbeds
of misinformation and disinformation
and despite all the promises and
new policies to match this information
was uh this information was rampant
in the 2020 election especially
targeting vulnerable
vulnerable communities for example
spanish language
ads run by the trump administ
but the trump campaign falsely accused
president
biden of in being endorsed by venezuelan
president
maduro the spread of disinformation
fell disinformation
fed upon itself until it arrived
at the capitol of the united states on
january 6
which cost five lives
the lives lost in the insurgents
uh insurgency were not the first cases
of these um platforms failure
or nor even the worst in 2018 facebook
admitted
a genocide of the rohingya people
in myanmar was planned and executed
on facebook 2020 saw the rise of
a of corona virus disinformation
on facebook platforms including
the um playing of the uh
we they called it the plan democ
this film got 1.8 million views and 150
000 shares before it was removed
disinformation like planned
pandemic made people skeptical
of the need for vaccines and almost
certainly
cost um contributed to the
horrible loss of life during the
pandemic
this information and also hops
hops platforms to spread
viruses i'm looking for a time
um to uh this information
also um hopes um
hops from platform to uh to to platform
it'd be
a actually was first
on youtube before it was on facebook and
instagram and twitter misinformation
regarding the election dropped
73 percent across social media platforms
after twitter permanently suspended
trump
um as well as um uh uh on
uh also
i'm sorry 30 seconds okay um and
also the uh capital insurgency and q
anon
but the question really is what
took so long the witnesses here today
have
demonstrated time and time again that
they um that they do not
um that self-regulation has not worked
they must be held accountable for
allowing disinformation and
misinformation
to to spread and
that is why i'll be introducing
the online consumer protection act
which i hope will earn bipartisan
support
and thank you i'll yield back general
lady yields back
uh the chair now recognizes mr bilarakis
ranking member
for the subcommittee on consumer
protection and commerce
for five minutes for his opening remarks
thank you mr chairman i appreciate it
thank you for participating in today's
hearing
all the the witnesses and the members
i've been thinking about this hearing
since our side
first requested this hearing last year
my time in congress has provided me
enough knowledge
about the history of the committee to
know what the telecommunications act
was and importantly what it wasn't
components of the that law have been
struck down by the courts
uh while other provisions are
interpreted and applied differently
than first conceived this is all a
departure
from congressional intent regardless of
what one thinks of whether
all of the communications decency act
was the right approach
the same members that voted for section
230
voted for that entire bill the statute
was meant to protect our society
specifically our children to our
witnesses today
here lies the problem for you you don't
want the federal government telling you
what parts of your company
you're allowed to operate so imagine
things that imagine things from our
perspective
when you pick and choose what parts of
the law you want
to follow i really do admire your
ingenuity
you have created some something truly
remarkable in my opinion
but with that power you must also be
good samaritans and you have an
obligation to be stewards
of your platform if your legal
department doesn't believe you're bound
to the intent of the law
i would hope your moral compasses will
many of my colleagues will raise
legitimate concerns
about the attack on the capital from
january and other colleagues can point
to what occurred
in our cities last summer these were all
incidents where social media escalated
tension
incited chaos and bred extremism
through echo chambers and algorithms
as the new republican leader quite an
honor
on the commerce protection and commerce
committee so the consumer protection and
commerce committee
i have been digging into how your
companies
operate that led me to run a survey
survey of my district following our big
tech hearing announcement
the conclusion is my constituents simply
don't trust you anymore with thousands
of responses
over 82 percent say they do not trust
big tech to be good stewards of their
platforms
or consistently enforce their policies
that includes my constituent who told me
we were providing
information to local families on teen
suicide risks on facebook
live stream it was blocked by
facebook another constituent said
she has seen countless teens be bullied
online
or simply not able to process a
devastating comparison game
that they are forced to deal with on
social media
others told me they stopped using your
services all together
out of fear and distrust one even told
me
they quit social media due to treatment
from your companies
over their families christian views
each one of these represents a story of
how your companies
have failed people and you'll be hearing
from my colleagues
with more of these stories about how big
tef
has lost its way highlighting a much
larger problem
people want to use your services but
they suspect your coders
are designing what they think we should
see and hear
by keeping us online longer than ever
and all with the purpose to polarize or
monetize us
disregarding any consequences for that
assault for the assault
on our inherent freedoms which we host
so
dearly so i don't want to hear about how
changing your current law is going to
hurt startups
because i've heard directly from them
accusing you of anti-competitive
tactics none of us want to damage
entrepreneurs what i do want to hear
is what you will do to bring our country
back from the fringes and stop the
poisonous
practices that drive depression
isolation
and suicide and instead cooperate with
law enforcement
law enforcement to protect our citizens
our kids
are being lost while you say you will
try to do
better as we've heard countless times
already
we need true transparency and real
change we need again
not empty promises from you and we've
heard that over and over again
the fear you should have coming into
this hearing today
isn't that you're going to get upgraded
by a member of congress it's that our
committee
knows how to get things done when we
come
together we can do this with you
or without you and we will thank you mr
chairman i go back
gentlemen yields back chair now
recognizes mr pallone chairman of the
full committee for five minutes for his
opening statement
thank you chairman doyle and chiakowski
for this very important hearing
we're here today because the spread of
disinformation and extremism has been
growing
online particularly on social media
where there are little to no guard rails
in place to stop it
and unfortunately this disinformation
and extremism doesn't just stay online
it has real world often dangerous and
even violent consequences
and the time has come to hold online
platforms accountable for their part
in the rise of disinformation and
extremism
according to a survey conducted by
earlier this month 30 percent of
americans are still hesitant
or simply do not want to take the covet
19 vaccine
on january 6 our nation's capital was
violently attacked
this month homeland security secretary
marcus identified domestic violent
extremism as the greatest threat to the
united states
and crimes against asian americans have
risen by nearly 150
since the beginning of the covet 19
pandemic
each of these controversies and crimes
have been
accelerated and amplified on social
media platforms through misinformation
campaigns
the spread of hate speech and the
proliferation of conspiracy theories
five years ago during the 2016
presidential elections
facebook google and twitter were warned
about but simply ignored
their platform's role in spreading this
information and since then the warnings
have continued but the problem has only
gotten worse
only after public outrage and pressure
did these companies make
inadequate attempts to appease critics
and lawmakers
but despite the public rebuke wall
street continued to reward the company
strategies
to promote misinformation and
disinformation by driving their stock
prices even higher
and now despite repeated promises to
seriously tackle this crisis
facebook google and twitter instead
routinely make minor changes to their
policies
in response to the public relations
crisis of the day
and they will change some underlying
internal policy that may or may not be
related to the problem but that's it
the underlying problem remains so mr
chairman it is now painfully clear that
neither the market nor public pressure
will force these social media companies
to take the aggressive action they need
to take to eliminate this information
and extremism from their platforms and
therefore it's time for congress and
this committee to legislate
and realign these companies incentives
today our laws give these companies and
their leaders a blank check to do
nothing
rather than limit the spread of this
information facebook google and twitter
have created business models that
exploit the humans brain preference
for divisive content to get americans
hooked on their platforms at the expense
of the public interest
and it isn't just that social media
companies are allowing this information
to spread is that in many cases they're
actively amplifying and spreading it
themselves
and fines to the extent they're levity
at all have simply become the cost of
doing business
the dirty truth is that they are relying
on algorithms to purposely promote
conspiratorial
divisive or extremist content so that
they can take money
more money and add dollars and this is
because the more outrageous and
extremist the content
the more engagement and views these
companies get from their users
and more views equals more money mr
chairman that's what it's all about more
money
it's crucial understand that these
companies aren't just mere bystanders
they're playing an ad role in the
meteoric
rise of different disinformation
extremism because they make money on it
so when a company is actually promoting
this harmful content i
question whether existing liability
protection should apply
members on this committee have suggested
legislative solutions and introduced
bills
the committee is going to consider all
these options so that we can finally
align the interests of these companies
with the interests of the public and
hold the platforms and their ceos
accountable when they strike
that's why you're here today mr
zuckerberg mr uh poochie
and mr dorsey you've failed to
meaningfully change
after your platforms played a role in
fermenting insurrection
in abetting the spread of the virus and
trampling american civil liberties
and while it may be true that some bad
actors will shout fire in a crowded
theater by
promoting harmful content your platforms
are handing them a megaphone
to be heard in every theater across the
country in the world your business model
itself has become the problem
the time for self-regulation is over
it's time to legislate
to hold you accountable that's what
we're going to do and i want to thank
you mr chairman mr doyle
and mrs yokowski as i know that you're
very serious about moving forward on
legislation
which we will do i promise everyone
thank you when i yield back
gentlemen yields back uh the chair now
recognizes miss rogers the ranking
member of the pool committee for five
minutes for her opening statement
thank you mr chairman years ago
when i joined big tech platforms i
thought
they would be a force for good i thought
that they would help us build
relationships
and promote transparency in congress
i can testify today i was wrong
that is not what has transpired you have
broken my trust
yes because you failed to promote the
battle of ideas
and free speech yes
because you censor political viewpoints
you disagree with
those polarizing actions matter for
democracy
but do you know what convinced me big
tech is a is a destructive force
it's how you've abused your power to
manipulate
and harm our children your platforms
are my biggest fear as a parent
i'm a mom of three school-aged kids
and my husband and i are fighting the
big tech battles in our household
every day it's a battle for their
development a battle for their mental
health
and ultimately a battle for their safety
i've monitored your algorithms i've
monitored where your algorithms lead
them
it's frightening and i know that i'm not
alone
after multiple teenage suicides in my
community i reached out to our schools
and we started asking questions
what's going on with our kids what's
making them feel so alone
so empty and in despair and this is what
i heard
over and over again from parents
pediatricians
school administrators and teachers
they're all raising the alarm about
social media a day doesn't go by that i
don't talk to friends and other parents
who tell me
they're 14 year old depressed she used
to love soccer
now they can't get her to do anything
she never gets off her device
or leaves her room i i think about a mom
who told me she can't leave her daughter
alone
ever because she harms herself for the
family who's recovering
after almost losing their daughter to a
p a predator
she met online
these stories are not unique to me or
eastern washington
i recently heard a young college student
who has lost
nine friends to suicide this is
unimaginable
the science on social media is becoming
clearer
between 2011 and 2018
rates of depression self-harm suicides
and suicide attempts exploded
among american teens during that time
rates of teen depression increased more
than 60 percent
with a larger increase among young girls
between 2009 and
15 emergency room admin admissions
for self-harm among 10 to 14 year olds
tripled and suicide
substantially increased
one study found during that time teens
who use their devices
for five or more hours a day were 66
more likely to have at least one suicide
related outcome
compared to those who use their device
just one
other study that teens who spend more
time online report
lower psychological well-being and more
feelings of loneliness
remember our kids the users
are the product you big tech
are not it's for children you exploit
and profit off of them big tech
needs to be exposed and completely
transparent for what you're doing to our
children
so parents like me can make informed
decisions we also expect tech to do more
to protect children
because you haven't done enough big tech
has failed to be good stewards of your
platforms
i have uh i have two daughters and a son
with a disability
let me be clear i do not want you
defining what is true for them
i do not want their future manipulated
by your algorithms
i do not want their self-worth defined
by the engagement tools you built
to attract their attention
i do not want them to be in danger from
what you've created
i do not want their emotions and
vulnerabilities taken advantage of
so you can make more money and have more
power
i'm sure most of my colleagues on this
committee who are parents and
grandparents feel the same way
over 20 years ago before we knew what
big tech would
become congress gave you liability
protections
i want to know why do you think you
still deserve those protections today
what will it take for your business
model to stop harming children
i know i speak for millions of moms when
i say
we need answers and we will not rest
until we get them thank you
thank the gentlelady gentlelady yields
back uh the chair would now like to
remind members that pursuant to
committee rules
all members written opening statements
shall be made a part of the record
i would now like to introduce our
witnesses for today's hearing
and thank them all for appearing today
first we have mark zuckerberg chairman
and chief executive officer facebook
sundar pichai chief executive officer
google
and jack dorsey chief executive officer
of twitter
uh we want to thank all three of you for
joining us today
we look forward to your testimony uh
each of you will
have five minutes to give your opening
statements
mr zuckerberg we'll start with you
you're recognized for five minutes
chairs palone czakowski and doyle
ranking members
rogers lata and billarachus and members
of the committee
i'm glad that this committee is looking
at all the ways that misinformation and
disinformation
show up in our country's discourse there
are important challenges here for our
society and we have to decide how we
want to handle speech that is
legal but harmful and who should be
responsible for what people say
misinformation is not a new problem it
was 200 years ago
that a congressman said that a lie would
travel from maine to georgia
while truth was still getting on as
boots disinformation has often been
spread through traditional media too
but the internet gives everyone the
power to communicate and that certainly
presents unique challenges
now people often say things that aren't
verifiably true
but that speak to their lived
experiences i think we have to be
careful restricting that
for example if someone feels intimidated
or discriminated against while voting
i believe that they should be able to
share their experience even if the
election overall was fair
i don't think anyone wild can only say
things that private companies judge to
be true
where every text message email video and
post has to be fact checked
uh before you hit send but at the same
time
we also don't want misinformation to
spread that undermines confidence
vaccines
stops people from voting or causes other
harms
in facebook we do a lot to fight
misinformation
we remove content that could lead to
imminent real world harm
we've built an unprecedented third-party
fact-checking program and if
something is rated false then we add
warning labels and significantly reduce
its distribution
we invest a lot in directing billions of
people to authoritative information
the system isn't perfect but it's the
best approach that we've found
to address misinformation in line with
our country's values
it's not possible to catch every piece
of harmful content
without infringing on people's freedoms
in a way that i don't be comfortable
with
the society our approach was tested
in 2020 when we took extraordinary steps
during an extraordinary election we
removed voting misinformation
banned hundreds of militias and
conspiracy networks including q and on
labeled posts that prematurely or
wrongly declared victory
and directed people to official results
we labeled over 180 million posts
we directed 140 million people to our
official voting information center
and we helped four and a half million
people vote
we did our part to secure the integrity
of the election
and then on january 6th president trump
gave a speech rejecting the results and
calling on people to fight
the attack on the capital was an outrage
and i want to express my sympathy to all
of the members
staff and capital workers who are to
live through this disgraceful moment in
our history
and i want to express my gratitude to
the capitol police who are on the front
lines in defense of our democracy
i believe that the former president
should be responsible for his words
and that the people who broke the law
should be responsible for their actions
so that leaves the question of the
broader information ecosystem
and i can't speak for everyone else the
tv channels radio stations news outlets
websites and other apps but i can tell
you what we did
before january 6th we worked with law
enforcement to identify and address
threats
during and after the attack we provided
extensive support in identifying the
insurrectionists
and removed post-supporting violence we
didn't catch everything
but we missed the hospital to those who
might do harm
and when we feared that he would incite
further violence we suspended the former
president's account
now many people are concerned that
platforms can ban elected leaders
i am too i don't think that private
companies should make so many decisions
like this alone
we need an accountable process which is
why we create an independent oversight
board
that can overrule our decisions and we
need democratically agreed rules for the
internet the reality is our country is
deeply divided right now and that isn't
something that tech companies alone can
fix
we all have a part to play in helping to
turn things around and i think that
starts
with taking a hard look at how we got
here now some people say that the
problem is that social networks are
polarizing us but
that's not at all clear from the
evidence or research polarization was
rising in america long before social
networks were even invented
and it's falling or stable in many other
countries where social networks are
popular
others claim that algorithms feed us
content that makes us angry because it's
good for business but that's not
accurate either
i believe that the division we see today
is primarily the result of a political
and media environment
that drives americans apart and we to
reckon with that if we're going to make
progress
now i know that technology can help
bring people together
we see it every day on our platforms
facebook is successful because people
have a deep desire to connect and share
not to stand apart and fight and we
believe that connectivity and
togetherness
are more powerful ideals than division
and discord
and that technology can be part of the
solution to the challenges our society
is facing
and we're ready to work with you to move
beyond hearings and get started on real
reform thank you
thank you mr zuckerberg uh now mr pachai
you are now recognized for five minutes
ranking member belarus full committee
chair palone
and full committee ranking member matt
morris rogers and members of the
committee
thank you for the opportunity to appear
before you today
to begin i want to express my sympathies
to those who have lost
loved ones to covet or the recent gun
violence
in boulder and atlanta in difficult
times
we are reminded of what connects us as
americans
the hope that we can make things better
for our families
best way to bring the benefits of
technology to more people over the past
three decades
we have seen hearts inspired the best in
society
by expanding knowledge powering
businesses
and providing opportunities for
discovery and connection
i'm proud that anyone can turn to google
for help
whether they are looking for vaccine
information learning new skills on
youtube
or using digital tools to grow their
businesses
in 2020 our products held 2 million u.s
businesses
and publishers generate 426 billion
dollars in economic activity
opportunity to help people at scale and
humble by the responsibility that comes
with it
thousands of people at google are
focused on everything from cyber attacks
to privacy to today's topic
misinformation
our mission is to organize the world's
information
and make it universally accessible and
useful
core to that is providing trustworthy
content and
opportunities for free expression while
combating
misinformation it's a big challenge
without easy answers
500 plus hours of video are uploaded to
youtube
every minute and approximately 15
of google searches each day are new to
us
18 months ago no one had heard of covet
19
sadly coronavirus was the top trending
search last year
staying ahead of new challenges to keep
users safe is a top priority
we saw the importance of that on january
6 when a mob
stormed the us capital google strongly
condemns these violent attacks on our
democracy
and moans the lives lost in response
we raised up authoritative sources
across our products
on youtube we removed live streams and
videos that violated our incitement to
violence policies
and began issuing strikes to those in
violation
of our presidential election policy he
removed apps from the play store for
inciting violence
and stopped ads referencing 2020
election or the capital rights as part
of our sensitive events policy
we were able to act quickly because we
were prepared
ahead of the 2020 elections our
reminders of how to register and vote
were viewed over 2 billion times
youtube's election resource information
panels have been viewed more than 8
billion times
we also work to keep campaigns safe from
cyber attacks
and protect platforms from abuse after
the december 8th
safe harbor deadline for states to
certify elections
the remote content from youtube that
alleged widespread fraud
changed the outcome of the election this
past year we've also focused on
providing quality information during the
pandemic
globally we've committed over 550
million dollars in ad grants
for covert related psas governments
health organizations and non-profits
on youtube our code information panels
have been viewed over 400 billion times
we also removed 850 000 videos and
blocked nearly 100 million code related
ads
throughout 2020 across all of this work
we strive to have transparent policies
and
enforce them without regard to politics
or point of view
our ability to provide a range of
information and viewpoints
while also being able to remove
misinformation
is possible only because of legal
frameworks like section 230
it's foundational to the open web which
has been a powerful force for good for
so many
i look forward to sharing more about our
approach today
and working together to create a path
forward for the web's
next three decades thank you
thank you mr chai the chair now
recognizes mr dorsey
for five minutes
thank you members of the energy and
commerce committee and its subcommittees
for the opportunity to speak with the
american people about how twitter may be
used
to spread disinformation in our
solutions
my remarks will be briefed so we can
move to questions and discussion
in our discussion today some of you
might bring up specific tweets
or examples and i'll probably have an
answer like my team will follow up with
you
i don't think that's useful i'd rather
us focus on principles and approaches to
address these problems
i'll start with ours we believe in free
expression
we believe in free debate and
conversation to find the truth
at the same time we must balance that
with our desire to for our service not
to be used to sow confusion
division or destruction this makes the
freedom to moderate content critical to
us
our process to moderate content is
designed to constantly evolve
we observe what's happening on our
service we work to understand the
ramifications
and we use that understanding to
strengthen our operations
we push ourselves to improve based on
the best information we have
much of what we're likely to discuss
today are entirely new situations world
has never experienced before
and in some unique cases involve elected
officials
and we believe the best way to face a
big new challenge is through narrowing
the problem to have the greatest impact
this information is a broad concept we
needed to focus our approach on where we
saw the greatest risk
if we had to have any impact at all so
we chose to focus on disinformation
leading to offline harm
and three categories to start
manipulated media
public health and civic integrity
many of you will have strong opinions on
how effective we are in this work
some of you will say we're doing too
much and removing free speech rights
some of you will say we're not doing
enough and end up causing more harm
both points of view are reasonable and
worth exploring
if we woke up tomorrow and decided to
stop moderating content we'd end up with
a service very few people
or advertisers would want to use
ultimately we're running a business
and a business wants to grow the number
of customers it serves
enforcing policy is a business decision
different businesses and services will
have different policies some more
liberal than others
and we believe it's critical this
variety continues to exist
forcing every business to behave the
same reduces innovation and individual
choice
and diminishes free marketplace ideals
this is a reality in many countries
today and is against the right of an
individual
this would also have the effect of
putting enormous resource requirements
on businesses and services
which would further entrench only those
who are able to afford it
smaller businesses would not be able to
compete and all activity would be
centralized into very few businesses
so how do we resolve these two
viewpoints one way is to create
shared protocols social media has proven
itself
important enough to be worthy of an
internet protocol
one that a company like twitter can
contribute to and compete on creating
experiences people love to use
we've started work on such a protocol
which we call blue sky
it intends to act as a decentralized
open source social media protocol
not owned by any single company or
organization
any developer around the world can help
develop it just as any company can
access its services
as an open protocol address the concerns
raised here
greater transparency is the strongest
benefit
anywhere anyone around the world can see
everything that's happening in the
network
including exactly how it works one
doesn't have to trust a company
just look at the source code second
since the base protocol is shared it
will increase innovation around business
models
recommendation algorithms and moderation
controls which are in the hands of
individuals
rather than private companies this will
allow people to experiment in a
market-based
approach finally it will allow all of us
to observe acknowledge and address any
societal issues that arise
much faster having more eyes on the
problems will lead to more impactful
solutions that can be built directly
into this protocol
making the network far more secure and
resilient a decentralized open source
protocol for social media is our vision
and work for the long term
we continue the cycle mentioned earlier
of constantly improving our approach to
content moderation in the short term
i hope our discussion today will focus
on more enduring solutions
one final note we are a bunch of humans
with the desire to make the world
around us better for everyone living
today and those that come after us
stakes are in and in execution
we commit to being open about these and
doing our best to remedy
what we control we appreciate the
enormous privilege we have in building
technologies to host
some of the world's most important
conversations and we honor the desire to
create better outcomes for everyone
who interacts with them thanks for your
time and i look forward to the
discussion
thank you mr dorsey well we've concluded
witness
opening statements at this time we will
move to member questions
uh i want to make sure that members are
aware that our witnesses are being
assisted
by counsel and during questions our
witnesses may briefly mute themselves to
seek advance
advice of counsel which is permitted uh
each member will have five minutes to
start asking questions of our witnesses
uh i ask everyone to please adhere to
that five-minute rule
as we have many people that uh ask
questions i will start
by recognizing myself for five minutes
gentlemen uh who's who's speaking
jeff duncan point of order yes sir
witness if the witnesses are advised by
council and we're not wearing them in
why would they need counsel
in in previous hearings we've always
permitted
witnesses to have counsel uh sometimes
you'll see them
at a hearing just leaning back and
talking to their counsel before question
but it's allowed under our rules and and
i just want to make members aware that
they may mute themselves while
it's going on they should be sworn in
but i yield back thank you
thank you um okay
gentlemen my time is short and i ask
that you make your responses
as brief and to the point as possible uh
if i ask you a yes or no question
i'm just looking for a yes or no so
please respond appropriately
i'm gonna start by asking all three of
you um
if your platform bears some
responsibility for disseminating
disinformation
related to the election and the stop the
steel movement that led to the attack on
the capital just a yes or no answer
mr zuckerberg chairman i think our
responsibility is to build systems that
can help
you talk about it i just want to get to
no answer okay yes or no do you do you
bear some responsibility
for what happened congressman our
responsibility is to make sure that we
build effective systems
not to answer the question uh mr pachai
yes or no
we always feel a deep sense of
responsibility but i think we work
hard uh this election effort was one of
our most substantive efforts is that a
yes or
no uh congressman it's a complex
question
uh we okay we'll move on uh mr dorsey
yes but you also have to take in the
consideration a broader ecosystem
it's not just about the technology
platforms we use
thank you thank you and and uh i agree
with that mr zuckerberg
independent analysis has shown that
despite all the things that facebook did
during the election
users still interacted with election
misinformation roughly 1.1 billion times
over the last year
the initial stop the steel group started
on facebook
and gained over 350 000 followers
in less than a day faster than almost
any other in your platform's history
and they were immediately calling for
violence in mid-december
you stopped promoting high quality news
outlets for election content
at a time when the this information was
at its height
and finally the fbi has released
numerous documents
showing that many of the
insurrectionists use facebook to
coordinate and plan the attack on
january 6th
so my question is how is it possible for
you not to at least admit that
facebook played uh a central role or a
leading role in facilitating the
recruitment planning
and execution of the attack on the
capitol
chairman my my point is that i think
that the responsibility here lies with
the people
who took the actions to break the law
and take and do the insurrection
and secondarily also uh
the the people who spread uh that
content
uh including the president but but
others as well
um with repeated rhetoric over time
um saying that the election was rigged
and encouraging people to organize
i think that those people bear the
possibility as well that was the point
that i was thinking i i understand that
but your platforms
supercharged that uh you you took what
a thing and magnified in 12 hours you
got 350 000 people
uh in your site you you you gen this up
your algorithms make it possible to
supercharge these kinds of opinions
i i think we're here because of what
these platforms enable
how your choices you know put our lives
in our democracy at
risk and many of us just find it uh just
just unacceptable i want to ask each of
you another question
uh do you think of vaccines that have
been approved for cobit 19 work
just yesterday do you think the vaccines
have been approved work mr zuckerberg
yes yes mr pichai
yes absolutely mr dorsey
yes but i don't i don't think we're here
to discuss our own personal opinions
i just want to know if you think the
vaccines work yes
yes however thank you okay so if you
think the vaccines work
why have your companies allowed accounts
that repeatedly offend your vaccine
disinformation policies
to remain up i mean according to report
just 12 accounts on facebook twitter and
instagram
account for 65 percent of all the
vaccine disinformation on your platforms
you're exposing tens of millions of
users
to this every day i have this
one too but my understanding is it's
similar so my my question is
why in the midst of a global pandemic
that has killed over half a million
americans
that you haven't taken these accounts
down that are responsible
for the preponderance of vaccine
disinformation on your platforms
uh will you all commit to taking these
platforms down
today mr zuckerberg
congressman we do have policy against
uh allowing a policy but when you take
the sights down today you still have 12
people up on your site doing this will
you take them down
congressman i would need to look at the
and have our team look at the exact
examples to make sure they're violated
because those still exist we we found
them as early as last night
uh mr pachai how about you uh
we've removed over 850 000 videos um
you still have people that are spreading
this information on your platforms
there's about 12 super spreaders we've
uh clear policies and we take down
contents some of the content
is allowed if it's people's personal
experiences but you know we
we definitely thank you mr dorothy i see
my time is getting inspired mr dorsey
will you take these sites tom you got
about 12 super spreaders will you take
them down
yes remember thank you
i see my time has expired uh i will now
yield to the uh ranking member mr latta
for his five minutes
i thank my friend for yielding uh amanda
todd
was just 15 years old when she hung
herself
amanda met a man i met a man online who
took inappropriate screenshots of amanda
and proceeded to follow her around the
internet and harassed her for years
he found her classmates on facebook he
would send them the picture he took over
to cope with the anxiety amanda turned
to drugs and alcohol
but he came too much for mr zuckerberg
clearly this todd was underage
so the photo that was shared that
harasser was illegal
do you believe that facebook fares any
responsibility for the role it played in
her death yes or no
sorry i was muted congressman that is a
it's a incredibly sad
story and i i i i think that we
certainly have a responsibility to make
sure that we're building
systems that can uh fight and remove
this kind of
harmful content and in the in the case
of
child exploitation content we've been
building systems for a long time
that use ai and we have
thousands of people working on being
able to identify this content and remove
it and i think our systems are generally
pretty effective at this
pretty short but would you say yes or no
then
sorry can you repeat that well in the
question
uh yes or no then any responsibility
congressman i believe that the
responsibility okay let me move on
because i got uh very short on time do
you believe that facebook should be
uh held accountable for any role in her
death yes or no
congressman the responsibility that i
think platforms should have
okay is to build up systems
i'm gonna have to think that just you're
not responding to the question
unfortunately stories like amanda todd
are only becoming more common
but we often talk about how your
platforms can be used for good or evil
the evil seems to persevere mr
zuckerberg you've publicly stated that
you support thoughtful chains to section
230
to ensure that tech companies are held
accountable for certain actions that
happen on their platforms
such as child exploitation what specific
changes do you support in section 230s
congressman i i would support two
specific changes
especially for large platforms uh
although i i want to call out that i
think for for smaller platforms i think
um we need to be careful about about any
changes that we make that remove their
their their immunity because that could
hurt competition so let me just
call on these for larger platforms i
think first
platforms should have to uh issue
transparency reports
that that state the prevalence of
content um
across all different categories of
harmful content everything from child
exploitation to terrorism to incitement
of violence to
um intellectual property violations to
pornography
whatever the different harms are and let
me answer now
where would those transparency reports
uh be be
reported to and and how often do you
think those should be coming out
well congressman as as a model um
facebook has been doing something to
this effect
for um every quarter right where we
where we report on
on the prevalence of each category of
harmful content and how effective our
systems are
at identifying that content and removing
it in advance
and and i think the the company should
be held accountable for having effective
systems to do that broadly
the second change that i would propose
is
um is is creating accountability for
a large platforms have effective systems
in place to moderate and remove
clearly illegal content so um things
like sex trafficking or
child exploitation or terrorist content
um and i think it would be reasonable to
condition
immunity for the larger platforms on
having a generally effective
um system in place to moderate clearly
illegal types of content
let me interrupt real quickly i'm
running really short on time because
i know when you're trusting me you're
talking about that you would you say
that platform should not be held
reliable
if a particular piece of content evades
its detection
so again uh that's one of the areas when
you're talking about the transparency
and
also the account employee i'd like to
follow up on let me
have to go on real quick uh mr chai uh
yes or no do you agree with
mr zuckerberg's uh changes in section
230
there are definitely good proposals
around transparency and accountability
which i've seen in various legislative
proposals as well
uh which i think are important
principles and and we would we would
suddenly uh welcome welcome legislative
approaches in that area
okay uh mr dorsey do you agree with uh
mr
zuckerberg yes or no and the changes in
230.
i think the ideas aren't transparent so
good i think it's going to be very hard
to determine what's a what's a large
platform in a small problem
platform and it may incentivize the
wrong things okay
someone's time has expired thank you
very much for my times according to you
back
here now recognize the chair schakowsky
subcommittee on consumer protection and
commerce for five minutes
thank you so much mr zuckerberg
immediately after the capital insurgency
um cheryl sandberg did an interview in
which she
insisted that the uh siege was
largely planned on small platforms
um that but court filings actually show
something quite the uh quite the
opposite
that the proud boys and oath keepers
um used facebook to coordinate in real
time
during the uh during the siege and so my
question
for you is will you admit today
um that facebook groups in particular
played a role in the uh in fermenting
the extremism that we saw and that led
to the
uh capital siege
uh congresswoman thanks for the the
question on this
in in the comment that that cheryl made
what what i believe that we were trying
to say
was um and and what i stand behind
um is what was widely reported at the
time that
uh after january 6. i'm sorry
to interrupt as many my colleagues have
had to do because we only have five
minutes
but would you say that and would you
admit that facebook played a role
congresswoman i think certainly there
was content on our services
and um and and from that perspective i i
think that there's
further work that we need to do to make
our services and moderation more
effective
i'm going to ask mr chai uh
a question um many companies have used
section 230
as a shield to escape um
consumer protection laws and i have a
bill
that would actually not protect
companies that
that do that and so mr pichai would you
agree
that that would be a proper um use
to not allow liability protection
for those who violate
consumer protection laws
uh congresswoman uh consumer abortion
laws are very important in many areas
like light we comply with copper and
hippa
i think the right approach is to have uh
legislation in applicable areas and have
us
i'm gonna have to i'm gonna have to
interrupt again
is that a yes that if the allah has been
broken
a consumer protection law that it would
not
there would not be liability protection
under section 230
for you
we rely on the liability protections to
actually take strong action
in particularly new types of content and
the christchurch shooting happens within
a few minutes
our teams have to make decisions about
the content to take down that certainty
is what we rely on but i agree with you
that we should have
strong consumer protection laws and be
subject to it and have
agencies like the ftc uh have clear
oversight
over those uh laws and how we comply
with them
let me just ask a real yes thank you a
real yes or no
quickly do you think that when you take
money to run advertisements that
uh promote disinformation that you
are exempt from liability
yes or no yes or no
uh mr zuckerberg
yes or no uh congresswoman i don't know
the the legal
answer to that but we don't allow
misinformation in our ads and any ad
that's been fact-checked is false we
don't allow it to run as an ad
okay and mr dougherty
uh again i also would need to review the
the legal president for it but
um we would uh we would not allow that
okay mr patrick uh we are subject to
ftc's deceptive ad practices so there
are statutes which apply to us
we remove over three billion bad ads
last year alone
okay let me ask um one more question
um do you think that such in 230
should be expanded to trade agreements
that are being made as happened in
the u.s trade agreement with mexico and
canada
yes or no
mr zuckerberg
congressman my primary goal would be to
help update section 230 to reflect the
the uh the kind of modern reality and
what we've learned over 25 years
but that said i do still think that
section 230 plays the foundational role
in the development of the internet and
companies
agreements mr um
congresswoman i think there's value in
it but if there are evolution of section
23 that should
apply and so in a flexible way being
able to do that
uh would be would be good i think mr
dorsey
i don't fully understand the
ramifications of what you're suggesting
so
after you've had anything to to have a
liability shield that would be
international
and ratified in trade agreements and i
think it's a bad idea okay gentlelady
time has expired
thank you chairdown recognizes mrs mr
bilarakis
uh subcommittee on uh ranking member of
the subcommittee on consumer protection
and commerce
for five minutes thank you appreciate it
uh dr uh mr dorsey
you have heard briefly about what i'm
hearing from uh
again in my district my opening remarks
you've heard them the other
key part with these stories that we're
hearing when we conduct these surveys
is how we uh empower law enforcement
and hearing last year we received
testimony
that since 2016 twitter has
intentionally curtailed
sharing threat data with law enforcement
fusion
centers here's the question you're well
aware
that on twitter and periscope that
traffic has increased
from bad actors seeking to groom
children for molestation
lured females into sex trafficking
sell illegal drugs and sight violence
and even
threaten to murder police officers
are you willing to reinstate this
cooperation
retain evidence and provide law
enforcement the tools to protect
our most vulnerable yes or no well
first trump sexual exploitation has no
place on our platform and i don't
believe that's true we work with
local law enforcement regularly so
you're saying that this is not true
uh what i'm telling you are you willing
to reinstate
reinstate in other words it's not it's
not going on now
reinstate this cooperation with law
enforcement
to retain evidence and provide law
enforcement
the tools to protect our most vulnerable
we we would love to work with you in
more detail on what you're seeing but we
work with
uh law enforcement regularly we have a
strong partnership
so you're saying that this is not true
what i'm telling you i don't believe
something like we'd
love to understand the specifics well
you commit
to to doing what i'm telling you you're
not doing
uh in the future and work with me on
this
we'll commit to continue doing what we
are doing
and what is that you're saying that
they're working on another way
local law enforcement okay well let me
go on to the next question but i'm going
to follow up with this
to make sure you're doing this i mean
our children's lives are in jeopardy
here
uh mr zuckerberg we have heard you
acknowledge mistakes about your products
before
there are now uh media reports of an
instagram for
under 13 being launched my goodness
between this and youtube kids
you uh you and mr chai have obviously
identified
a business case for targeting this age
bracket
with the content and i find that very
concerning
targeting this particular age bracket 13
and under
given these free services how exactly
will you be making money
or are you trying to monetize our
children too
and get them addicted early and will you
be allowing your own children to use
this site with the default settings
we're talking about they again they site
that
apparently is being watched uh for
children under 13 and under
or under 13 actually can you please
answer that question for me
congressman we're early in thinking
through
uh how this service would work there is
clearly a a large number of people under
the age of 13 who would want to use a
service like instagram we currently do
not allow them to do that i think would
it be
beneficial what would be beneficial
uh for to our children to launch this
kind of service
well congressman i think helping people
stay connected with friends
and learn about different content online
is broadly positive there are clearly
issues that need to be thought through
and worked
out including how parents can control
the experience of
of kids especially kids under the age of
13 and
we we haven't worked through all of that
yet so we haven't uh
kind of formally uh announced the plans
but
but i i think that something like this
could be quite helpful for a lot of
people
excuse me okay i'll recall my